Okay. Beautiful. All right. Let me see if I can see the comments properly. Marcus Dugas.
What's going on, bro? One of our day, not quite day one, but almost day one. What's
up Dev Nate? What's going on? Thad. We're seeing some OGs in here. Stephanie Prather,
what's going on? Jackson, my friend. What's up? Says he can hear us. Aaron Vogler, Fred
Sommer, Steven Pease, Richard Martes, Bo Hicks. All right. I think we wait just two, three
minutes and then I think we're just going to get into it. But what do you think about
that? Does it sound good? Let's do it. That works. I also recognize a bunch of these folks.
You can do some OGs in here, man. Yeah, I'm seeing some names. There's Porter, by the
way. What's up, Porter? He's probably out working on the farm this early morning. Matt
Torres. Guys, this is an exciting day. Yeah, let's just get into it. Let's just get into
it because I want to spend as much time as possible. We have 53 minutes and I want to
get as much possible. So guys, welcome to the call. Actually, let me do the everyone
tag really quick. That's what I'll do. I'm not even going to do any housekeeping. Why
doesn't it not let you do everyone from your computer? Is that the dumbest thing ever?
Dude, it's so weird. Like I, when I do a good lot of my group, I have to like open the group
in a different window and then comment in there or do it from my phone. I don't know.
It's like Mark Zuckerberg's figured out how to look like an alien on his own, but he can't
figure out how to use the everyone tag.
Yeah, or the whole issue. You connect to Zoom, I guess, right? Like the virtual is doing
it natively and why is it so hard to do that?
It's so hard. Like why are you making it so hard, Zucks? Okay, hold on. Let me see if I
can get it. There we go. Okay. At everyone. Boom. By the way, I had the weirdest dreams,
dude. David Beckham's son was in my dream. Dude, what a weird dream I had. Oh my goodness.
People were stealing my stuff. So we're, we're trying to get back to reality here now that
I am already go. Okay. Let's see. Brayden Johnson, what's up? Raphael, what's up? Chris
Art, what's up? Emily Fisher, what's up? Okay. We got a crowd. Guys, welcome to the call.
Welcome to the live call. We have Ryan Dalton joining us again. Mr. 80, is it 87 or 86 K?
I float between 83 and 87. He's a float. He's a float. I love that. He is our, not basically,
he is our very first student ever to achieve this milestone. He has got a run rate of he's
going to be hitting a, he's, you've already made a million dollars in doing this business,
but now we're at big boy numbers, which is a million dollars per year as our run rate
and it's only climbing. So anyway, congrats to you, bro. Yeah, man. Thanks. Yeah. Homegrown
in digital landlords and art of reselling. I love it, dude. I love it. So, okay, guys,
here's what we're going to do. Jason already said he's stoked for this. Juan Martinez,
another day one. I'm loving some of these OGs. They're, I think they, they're excited
as well because they've been hobnobbing different stuff together. So here's what we're going
to do. We, Ryan has been working on something for about 15 months. Is that about right?
Yeah. And I'm going to let him just share five minutes of the story behind it. And then
literally this entire, what I'm going to have him do is share his screen and I'm going to have him
show you guys what he has built and how seamless this is. And then at the end of this call,
we are going to be offering to a certain number of people, we're going to be offering a beta,
we're going to be taking on beta students. We've already started doing this with a select few,
but we're going to be taking on some beta students. So at any point, if you, if this
looks interesting to you, stick around to the end, because this would be the time to test this out.
What do we have? Like five people that have just, for a few days, we haven't really had
many issues at all. So when we say beta, basically you're just getting a deal at this point.
Yeah, you're basically getting a deal. I mean, it's not, it's not like, see, beta will sometimes
be used like incomplete, but that's not the case. Like it's very complete. You're, you're just like
one of the first users to know what you think. Now keep in mind, I will say this, I'll say this at
the end too, because we'll, we'll drop a link or whatever for the people that want to do beta.
This is a paid beta. So, you know, that just keep that in mind. This isn't a free base of paid beta
because this is a, something that's taken a lot of time, a lot of money, a lot of effort. Secondly,
because it's beta and there is a discount, expect that there could be a flaw. There could
be something that goes sideways and you have to be patient. That's why the discount is offered.
We don't anticipate there being that much that's weird about it or that goes sideways. However,
keep that in mind. So don't, don't hit up Ryan and say, oh my gosh, this, this little thing
happened. I couldn't log in instantly. Like there's going to be potentially some hiccups. So
that's part of the game. So just you've been warned. Okay. That said, I don't anticipate
there being many issues at all. But so Ryan, tell these guys what, what this, like why you built
what you built and guys, I, the title of this stream is what I think is going to describe this
tool as I think it's going to be the only tool you're ever going to need to scale your agency.
And I think the challenging part is going to be trying to figure out what to show them, what not
to show them because we only have 45 minutes. So right. All right. Let's get into it.
Yeah. We'll show them all the, all the fun stuff. It's all fun, but we'll show, we'll show them
good stuff. So, um, all right. So I've been in rank and rant for about two and a half years.
And I got into this and realized pretty quickly that there's not
a great solutions out there for tools. So we're usually, what happens is this,
as people get into this industry, they're like, Hey, listen, I want to do local lead generation
and they've got to go find a CRM. They got to find the right CRM, right? So their content relation
or their customer relationship manager, they've got to go find a keyword tool. They've got to
go find a site analyzer. They've got to go find programmable voice and messaging. So what happens
is inevitably everyone that does this business model is using three to four, at least different
tools at minimum, uh, that are all like scattered. And the problem with that is,
is the data doesn't talk to each other, right? So this was my frustration is there was not
anything out there. And, and, you know, there are some tools that do more things than others,
right? But there wasn't one that did it all. And so I found myself using a whole bunch of different
tools and having to manually connect that create the connective tissue and places where my data
needs to talk to each other. So, uh, I see we got, uh, Deb Nate on the call. Um, he said he used
version 1.0. So version 1.0 was a no-code solution connecting, uh, some of these things together,
where the users basically through like a sort of a mini course could go and connect these using sort
of off the shelf tools. Um, that was, that was great. We've got, you know, a lot of users that
use that, but it also had limitations that have a lot of limitations that I wanted to
make the next version to be a lot better. And so that's what we did. Right. So built, uh,
rank and run engine, uh, as it exists today. And it's got, uh, really everything that you need
to build an agency, no matter what level you're at. Right. So you can have, you know, be a million
dollar run rate, or you could be like at your first day or your first couple of sites or whatever.
And you've got everything you need in-house to grow and build your agency.
So I know that there wasn't like, besides Dave, uh, Dev, Nate, there was, you had at least a couple
hundred people that did this. Yeah, we've had over 300 that used it. And so it was so, it was like
unexpectedly popular. Like it started with just what I was using, like, Hey, this is how I built
my agency. And a buddy of mine, Alex, he, uh, he was like, Hey dude, you should have let other
people try this and see how this works. Cause this works really well. Cause I set it up for him and
worked great for him. And I was like, all right. And so I allowed, you know, really anyone to have
access to it. And a lot of people really liked it, but I also got like consistent feedback. Like
it was more involved to set up phone numbers. People have to set up these, you know, campaigns
and Twilio. And basically I looked at all of the places of version one that people said, Hey,
this part, can we make this better? And then built the version that we have today.
Yep. And like another, another person I know, uh, Mike V used it to scale. Uh, we had Mike V on
a couple of weeks ago. He's just hit $40,000 a month. So,
it was awesome. Uh, but he also set this up for me. It was, it was low cost. It was easy to use.
It was straightforward. And that's what we, we really enjoyed about it. So, um, I gave you co-hosts.
I think what we do is get in there and let's just show the tools that we have today. So,
just show the tool and show some of the things that this is going to streamline.
Some of the things it's going to eliminate and just kind of from a, I mean, there's going to be
a ton of stuff that we're not going to be able to get to, but basically, uh, this is going to be
a CRM, a, a search volume, a due diligence, basically all wrapped into one. That's going
to allow you to a project. I mean, everything all wrapped into one. Yeah, that's it. So the,
the goal is for, not the goal, what we did is to make it an all in one platform
to build scale and automates the tagline, right? So you can get it at rankinronengine.com. We'll
talk more about that at the end of the call, but, uh, that was the point is to make it all in one.
And you can read about it here. If you want to see like a super short seven minute demo, um,
I made one for you to just click on this to see, uh, you know, top to bottom, how it all works,
but I'm going to walk you through it and show you guys, uh, we've already got a bunch of people
that are starting to sign up for it. So pretty excited about, uh, about this. So let's start with,
um, just overview of the platform. I'm going to grab some water. Keep going. Great. Do your thing,
man. Uh, well, I'm just going to give you guys an overview of this platform and I'm going to show
you guys and gals, uh, what the value is for your agencies and why I built this, right? So ultimately
what I found is, is that a lot of people were using all these things in this left column.
There are free tools that were really bad or paid ones that were expensive
or having to use a bunch of paid tools that were expensive. Uh, and it really became like,
I don't know, expensive to, to run, to run an agency. And I noticed this cause I'm big on
running a lean agency and having like the most affordable and high performing way to do every
element of this business model. So, um, I'm going to walk you through this left hand column. Uh,
I think that you guys might be able to, uh, see this. If anyone can't see it, if I need to zoom
in, let me know. I'm going to make it a little bit bigger, but if you guys can't see it, let me know.
So, all right. I'm going to take you through each of these, uh, core features of rake and run engine
and show you how all these work together to build an agency. Right. The first thing is task tracker.
So, um, a lot of people will use things like, uh, Google sheets or notion or, uh,
monday.com or Trello, some of these organizational tools, um, that don't tie into the rest of your
agency. And so, um, I found that in my agency, I've either created or assigned 3000 tasks
to my team. So either ones that I've done or my team has done, and that has consistently moved
the needle forward. So I wanted to integrate that into this platform where you can keep track of
immeasurable, right? Anything in business needs to be measurable. So you're measuring how much
progress that you're making and what needs to be accomplished for your agency and allows you to
scale already with, you know, what's directly in here. So if you want to bring in your team,
you're going to bring in VA's, it's really easy to just, you know, add them as a user to your
company and you can, uh, keep track of that. Right? So there's four categories here. There's
what needs to be done now, what we're working on in progress, what's been done is complete
and what maybe has some kind of blocker, right? This is project management 101 stuff. So, um,
I run a, uh, a hundred million dollar project, uh, for, um, the company that I worked for.
And, um, this is based on those principles, right? Project management principles, right? Because
that's what your business is. You're managing your business and you have got to make sure
that you're, uh, tuned into what's most important to move the needle forward.
So I'm not going to spend a lot of time on this part. Uh, it's pretty straightforward,
right? You put in, you know, your task title, right? So to do more bill events,
my keyboard is super loud. So I'm going to try to type a bunch, put in details here about
whatever that task is, uh, set priority levels, uh, you know, you can add your labels.
So, you know, what's involved to do bill events. Yeah. Uh, that you can add different options down
here, right? So we want to put new bill events and add it. There it is. Add it in, uh, task owner.
You can decide yourself or your team. Uh, so here I'm assigning it to me and then, uh, everything
matters about due dates. So we're going to do this on Halloween. And then you can all color code it
because I'm a nerd like that, right? So when we create this, you can, you know,
add images and all that kind of stuff. It's not, let me click, hold on and make this a little bit
smaller. Oh, task details is required. Um, test. Okay. And so you will begin to fill this up with
what's most important for your agency. So you can add images, you can, you know, like tag people,
put in comments. This is mission control. So, uh, I have used this extensively in version 1.0 and
it's been the, the most, uh, valuable thing for me to go back and measure what kind of results
am I getting and where am I putting my attention? Cause where you put your attention is where you're
going to get your results. All right. And that's what task tracker is about something that's a little
bigger. Real quick. Um, just, I think I might've missed this or maybe you covered it already.
Or if my team, I have a VA or whatever, I can assign this task to them.
Totally. So if I go in here and I click edit right now, I'm the only user in here.
Okay. You can assign people here and you can assign the owner and you as the task right now
only shows me, but you could go and you can click on your users and you can add, um, more users in
here. All right. So you want to add more, you want to add your team and, uh, you can add seats
basically. Yeah. So again, where you put your attention is where you can measure your results
and that's what task tracker is about. Right. So pretty straightforward project management stuff.
So now we're getting to like the meat of this. This is a due diligence and we covered this, uh,
over the last week. I'm not going to like deep dive into this. Uh, on last week's call, we showed
this Nick, you think like talk a little bit about this, but not going to the level of detail of
last week or you want to go forward? I definitely think we should talk about this and guys, I think,
um, you know, we've been taught for a long time. I mean, months, we, people have been said, you know,
what's the state, like what's, uh, uh, the search volume that gives us confidence to go into what,
what is the minimum search volume? And we've purposely not necessarily said, well, on this
tool, it's this because we haven't, we don't have any control over Semrash or mangles or anything.
Now we do. And so now we're going to be able to go in and over the next month, as we're also,
you know, playing around with it, putting our agencies, uh, completely on this tool,
we're going to be able to come up with a minimum search volume to say, Hey, if the tool says this,
you can, you know, with 90% confidence, be sure there's going to be enough search volumes. I'm
really excited about that. But any of you guys that are paying for Semrash and, uh, then you're
paying for that tool and this tool and whatever this right here is going to do everything that
you need. If it's just for this feature alone, like I realized I was paying 120 is $129 or $119
for Semrash. I still haven't figured out, is it SCM rush or is it Semrash? I I've gone back and
forth. I don't even know what the proper term is, whatever it is. Only thing I use that tool for
is search volume. Like from the beginning, I've probably spent a hundred bucks a month, I spent
let's just call it a thousand bucks a year, which is less than it is for, I probably spent five to
$10,000 on the search function of Semrash. And that is this one piece of this tool.
What am I going to talk about real quick, or I would cover it a little bit, but tell them how
this data is, it doesn't go through any third parties. It comes directly into this tool.
Yeah, absolutely. So, um, you're looking at due diligence records here. So, uh, you know, we'll
dive into this and how we get this data, but I realized that there's such a variance in what
data is out there. At the end of the day, uh, you gotta have the most accurate data to make decisions
about which markets to enter. So this is a due diligence tool that automates this process,
right? Where you will put in the essential information that you need to understand your
market. And then you're going to get it spit back out, you know, what exactly the keyword,
search volume, cost per click, and then your competitor analysis looks like.
So, um, speeds up the due diligence process tremendously. Uh, you can pretty quickly
assess if you've got a good market to go into, um, because it's also going to pull in population.
So, um, I looked at like where this data comes from and what the most accurate data is. So this
is being pulled straight out of a keyword planner where I'm getting it straight from the source.
This is coming straight from Google. And so Google is saying, Hey, this is what the search
volume is. This is what the cost per click is. And if you're not getting, you know, uh, a return,
it's basically Google saying, we don't know. We can't tell you. So one of my frustrations was
some of these other tools like main goals or whatever, um, would give a number for that,
but it was a guess. And when I would run ads, it would be like very wrong.
And so, um, having this pulled in with my due diligence into the same records, uh, for competitor
analysis, you know, really allowed me to see what a picture, a snapshot of that market looks
like. Um, so let's do an example. Um, Hey, real quick, Ryan, before we go any further,
just a quick question from Gina. She said, can you add attachments or documents to the task?
Yeah, sure can. So, um, you can upload files. Amazing. Yeah. So you can just add,
yeah, um, uh, like a PDF or something like that. You could add to it. That's awesome.
You have images, logos, whatever you'd add. Yeah. Beautiful. And then real quick, one more thing,
just so we're keeping on top of these, Daniel Kelly says, so does rank and rent engine do away
with the need to have multiple subscriptions? Answer is yes. Assuming that he's talking about
having man goals and SEM rush and these things. This is the old guys, the only tool you need to
scale. That's why I call it that live. That's called the live this, but anyway,
I think that's what he's asking. Um, yeah. Absolutely. That's the, that's how we built it.
This is the, this is the definitive tool that you need for this industry, right? So for local lead
generation, you don't need anything else to grow. Now you may have some like, you know, something
that you do with Adobe Photoshop for your editor images or whatever. It didn't have stuff like that,
but like the essentials from local lead generation are here. This is everything you need.
Beautiful. Okay. Sorry to cut you off. I just want to stay on top of that.
So, but real quick, I just want to say on this guys, this is this again, the cool part about
this from what everything that I've seen so far is each one of these, like for example,
task tracker. I remember at one point in my career, I paid for a program or a software
called pipe drive, right? All pipe drive does is exactly what task track tracker does, which is,
I mean, it does it for your clients or whatever, which we're going to show you that this also does,
but basically you just create these cards and you drag them. That's basically all that it did. And
I was, I think it was like 50 bucks a month. And that's what task trackers now due diligence.
I don't know about you guys, but I was one of those people in the beginning. I had stacks. I
used to print off the due diligence. I would print off like 50 at a time, keep them on my desk.
I'd take a pen and I was writing the information that I had stacks of these
hundreds of these due diligence sheets. And then I thought I graduated and I was so smart and I
went to Google drive. And now I have so many, and I've got, you know, folder inside a folder,
inside a folder, inside a folder, inside a folder to get to, you know, and I've got it by niche and
all this different stuff. Whereas this now I can log into my tool. I have my tasks and I have my
search volume and I have my due diligence cards. And I think I asked this last time, is there a
limit to how many of these due diligence you can have?
Yeah. You've got to map out your empire, right? You've got to map out where you're going to put
your, your sites. So it's unlimited. Right.
And one other thing I like a lot who here has done the research on, let's say Las Vegas concrete.
It doesn't look good or it does look good or whatever. You decide not to do it. And then like
six months later, you're like, Oh, I should go into Las Vegas concrete or somebody hits you up
and says, you know, you get a referral or whatever. And you're like, I remember doing
the due diligence and you go back and you're like, Oh, I should probably do it again to see
if it's like up to date. Guess what? All you have to do now is push one button.
You go to it, you push refetch, correct? And it automatically runs the entire due diligence
right within, what is it? Two and a half seconds, three seconds.
It's pretty much instant. So you can refetch it or you can go in here and here's a, here's one for
Brick Masonry in Nashville. Click edit. If you want to switch out your keywords, right? Like maybe
we don't like retaining wall, but we like, you know, brick wall. I don't know. I'm just
going to make up something. And we want to update our keyword because we found that maybe it's
successful in other markets, right? We just go in here and we just update the location and it's
going to refetch that data. So brick wall is a tool. Actually it's not a bad keyword, 140
search volume. I don't know what the cost per click is, but you just edit that record and it
pulls in the latest competitor data as well, right? So their domain age, authority, backlinks,
page authority, citation flow, and trust flow. And it'll refresh all that for you where, you know,
if you're kind of waiting, kind of eyeing it, right? Maybe, you know, your work sure, like your
market was marked to be determined up here. And you're like, all right, I got to look at Masonry
in Nashville. Like, all right, this is pretty good. And you can mark it and go.
Um, let's just do a little math. Let's say you're, how long do you think it takes to do,
take this tool out? Let's say the standard way. How long do you think it takes you to do a due
diligence? I would guess for me, probably about 30 minutes. Yeah, that's probably right. I'll say 30
minutes. Let's say you're average. Let's say you're not making that much money. Your time's worth
$100 an hour, right? So let's say that 50 bucks every time you do one of these, what it costs you.
And let's say that you do, you know, for every area, you have to look at 10. So let's say to do
10 sites, you have to look at 100. So 10 is up by 100. That costs you $5,000 worth of your time
to look at due diligence. You just literally eliminated that with this tool. I mean, it's
insane. It takes you instance three seconds or less to get the same information. It take, it would
take you 30 minutes to get. Yeah. Yeah. Look, I mean, money loves speed, right? You said it a
million times. It's true. The faster that you can do this stuff, the more quickly you can make
accurate decisions to go into a market. Not to mention you might miss something because
you're human and you, you, you know, incorrectly anyway. So of everything, dude, the search volume
and the due diligence, this might be my favorite part of the entire tool, but piece of it.
Yeah. We spent a lot of time on the due diligence part to really make sure this is
going to grab what you need. I see some of these questions in the chat. So
I'll just talk through, when you add a record, this only works in the US for right now. We're
going to expand to other markets outside the US, but you know, your country is the United States.
You pick your state, you put in your city, you put in your niche, call driven, yes or no. That's
just a reminder, like, you know, are we in the right niche? You're putting your primary keywords.
This is your money keyword. Like this is the one, this is masonry, this is artificial grass,
this is concrete contractor, this is fence installation. And then you put up your core
keywords, which are the next six. So those are the ones that you're going to build your service
pages out of when you build service pages. These are, you know, your core keywords and it covers
that and the due diligence modules, right? And then you need to look at how many active
businesses there are. Maybe now you don't know you market TBD and then you put in your top three
competitor domains, right? So I just grabbed some URLs here. These are just kind of ones I, you know,
put in and you're going to put in these domains. You can put in an available domain. So this is
grayed out right now because I've already added it. But you'll put, you'll put in this big brick
energy Nashville for a brick mason, but you can, you know, edit whatever your domain is that,
you know, you check GoDaddy for to make sure you could buy the domain. Loading fruit, TBD,
go or no go TBD, or maybe you already have a vibe for it and then you update the location,
right? And it's going to pull in that data automatically. So you can see that it just
loaded while we've been talking here, right? So all that data that you normally have to go
type in domain age, like pull up domain authority, like how many backlinks, right? Like
that is completely unnecessary. That's one of the things that frustrate me most is
you just can make it the right API calls to the right services and you're going to get
the data that you need. Yep. Beautiful. So let's just rapid fire through some of these questions
because I know we're going to be just cutting it close here. So real quick, Richard said,
I'm doing my business with my spouse. So can I assign a task to both of us
or can she edit a task without being an admin? Yeah. So there's one company admin. So under users,
there's the one admin, you can add someone as a seat on there who is, you know, an administrator,
or you can both use the same account, you know, with the same password. If you want equal admin,
right? So I don't know how you feel about that, but the invited users will appear here. So if you
want to add somebody in, you can both be on the task. So this task here, you can assign, you can
have, you know, the owner, you can have the person that's assigned to it and all that is going to
appear just like RRB, right? There's my initials, Ryan Dalton. You would see here on the task who
it belongs to. Beautiful. So it's designed for collaborative, you know, working together, right?
Beautiful. Okay. So answer that one is yes.
Prabh says, just hopping off, can we use this for SEO? Of course you can use this for SEO.
LeadGen is SEO. We're just doing LeadGen. We're just doing SEO for ourselves, right?
Richard says, is it pulling the competitor data on its own without entering that information?
So I think your question is, is it pulling your top three by just virtually knowing what the market
is? And the answer is no, you have to go in and you have to look at what your top three are, right?
Because, you know, you've got to go see what those top three websites are for the ones that you want
to beat. But all you have to do is paste the URL in here. So which is a good thing, by the way,
because if not, maybe it would pull in like a home advisor and stuff like that. And we all know that
home advisor, even though they may be your spot number one, they're not the same type of a
competition as a local competitor, because Google likes to give the spot to the local. So yeah,
you're going to go in, you're going to just choose those three, the ones that you keep seeing over
and over, and boom, then you're going to have that information. So it's going to take you just a
second. Bo asks the same question, how is it picking the top three competitors? So that's one,
you're going to put in the top three competitors. Again, we can't, unless we had a formula that said,
get rid of home advisor, do this, do this. There's no way that we could do that, because it would
just be pulling the top three. And sometimes that would be the home advisor or Angie's list, which
in which case it wouldn't be accurate. So that you do put in the top three competitors.
Yeah. Yeah. There's limits to good software and automation. Like the best way to do it is to have
a human in the loop, right? You want to have a human that is looking at that data and saying like,
yeah, these are the top three, you plug those in and then everything else is done automatically
for you after that. Okay. Beautiful. I agree. Gina says, I have stuff scattered everywhere.
This is amazing. I a hundred percent agree with you. And then Bruce has said to this DD tool,
find your top competitors. Well, no, that's, we covered that as well. Okay. Last one, Daniel
Kelly says, not related to ranking or Angie, but would appreciate some input on choosing a niche.
I joined last week. I spent a while looking at a tree service, but it seems almost impossible to
rank for an ultra competitive. So I'd appreciate some ones Nick would recommend. Okay. I'll comment
with some of the recommended ones. So we don't have to stop on that one. Daniel, just give me a
second. I'll respond there. And then Kirk says, perhaps it could screen out. Yeah, it could. But
again, as Ryan said, I think having a human in the loop is the best option, but it's not something
that we can't update going forward. And then Raphael says, do I still need to use Google
keyword planner for ads? No, you don't. So we can jump around here. We don't have to go in order.
Uh, so I'm sure you keyword planner. So here's keyword planner. Uh, we're just going to do old
faithful. Let's do concrete. It's a contractor. By the way, let me point something out quick,
quick, quick. Um, everyone thinks concrete saturated literally yesterday when I was on
the call, uh, with, I was going to call it Jason. He had to hop off. Jason already had to hop off,
get on a closing call. He got on like 15 minutes later, 30 minutes later, and he closed a $1,400
a month deal in concrete. There are deals out there. I'm not saying that you should go into
concrete, but if you look hard enough, there's still deals. So, um, yeah, use old faithful for
us. Yeah, we, we can, we can switch up. We do, uh, we'll do Mason. Let's do a fresh one. Right. So,
um, I still get deals in concrete. Uh, we're we'll have a closing call this week for concrete. So,
uh, I don't think it's, well, let's, let's do another one. Let's do, uh, let's do Mason. Right.
So this data is your keyword planner, right? So think about how much time is lost hopping
between all these platforms. You're not only paying for them, but you're jumping between them
back and forth and it's, it's slowing you down. So, um, this is something that I felt very acutely.
I don't want to have to always be jumping back and forth. You also have data fidelity issues when
that happens, right? Like, am I making sure that I'm putting the right data in? Is my team putting
the right data in? This is pulling straight from the source. This is pure keyword and, uh,
calls per click and search volume data. So, uh, we did Masonry, Nashville area, search volume,
calls per click. You can see the PPC competition level, right? So, um, the, you know, low, uh,
and then the competition is just shown here as low, right? So, um, it also pulls your low, uh,
top of page bid and your high top of page bid to see what it's going to cost you to get at the top
of the page. Uh, and then you're obviously your average monthly search volume, uh, over the course
of the last year. And then related keywords, right? So all the Mesa Green near me, um, if it
doesn't have the data for that, it's not going to make up a number. This, again, this is what
frustrated me about some of these other tools is it will make up a number based on, you know,
whatever data brokers are pulling from, because that's what these keyword planners do is they go
buy data from, from places. And, um, I found this to be pretty unreliable. I want as accurate as I
can get. And if Google doesn't know, like, I need to know that, right? So, uh, this is a great
example of the, like, you know, you put in that core keyword, this is my primary keyword and,
you know, I'm going to get that, that search data to pull up. Beautiful. So I'm just looking at
comments. Uh, Mike V is a tool limited to the United States. Obviously not all the features,
but some of the, uh, the competitor analysis features, that kind of stuff. Um, of course that,
that's, this is just beta. So we're going to be working on that, but yes, it is. Um, Aaron Smith
said, I joined a bit late. How do we access this tool? We're going to be getting to that here in
just a moment in the next 15 minutes. So hold on one second on that. And Richard said, is there
a way to save previous keyword planner searches? Oh, that's a great idea. Yeah. So I've been talking
to the developers about that. What we'd like to do is have a keyword search history where you can
just select if you want to go back and look at that, that doesn't exist now, but you guys,
this community drives the development of this tool. This is made by people doing rank and rent
for people doing rank and rent. So, you know, as you guys are using this tool, I've got a,
you know, up here in this corner, I've got a support button that you can click and you can say,
hey, I've got this idea. Hey, why don't we do this? I'm going to take what the,
what the people want and build it. Right. So things like that, that we continually,
we'll make this the best in class tool for this industry. And, uh, you know, you guys are,
are the ones that are informing that. Beautiful. What else should we cover? We have time to cover
like, what else do you want to cover, man? We have programmable. So I want to talk about the
biggest thing that you need for retention in this industry. And so let me tell you in 30 seconds,
how I know this. I will also, in my agency, close sites for site owners. And one of the things that
I coach the site owners who bring sites to me, they want to get them closed and on a profit
split. Basically I'll say, Hey, you need to have a text message SMS notification set up in your
programmable voice so that the business owner knows that you're getting those leads over to them,
right? Where every time a call comes in, they get a text message that says you have a new
lead from, and it shows the number. So what I've done is, um, when you guys get a number here,
your first ones are included for free with your subscription. This has a full suite of programmable
voice and messaging. So you can go in here and you can, you know, pull up this number and this
one is for a little rock concrete, right? That exists. It's not a real site. I'm sure it's a
real site for someone under that domain, but I just put some information in here. Um, and so you
could put in your, you know, all this information in here, right? So you can put in your tracking
number. You're, um, uh, pulled in automatically. You can put in your forwarding number and then
down here, all of this stuff right here is about retention. So, um, when the call comes in, you
want to be able to enable spam filtering or not. So one of the key complaints that business owners
give is about spam. And they're like, Hey, I get great leads, but I've got this spam coming in.
All you got to do is enable spam filtering. And now when someone calls, they press, uh, one to
connect to the business owner, right? They hear a message that says something like, um, press,
thank you for calling, uh, press one to be connected to one of our team. And the call will
actually not go through until someone presses that input. So it saves you with one click, uh,
spam concerns from your business owners. Um, you can choose your whisper message, male or female.
It's also got state law compliance for call recordings. So, uh, you can click this right
here to play it and listen to it if you want to. But basically it's just that message that says
this call may be monitored or recorded for quality assurance or training purposes, which is,
um, required by state law. If you do two party, uh, call recordings or one party call recording
or other, right? So not true for every state, but it's true in a lot of states. And so I just leave
it on by default to be compliant. Um, and then you can put in your whisper messages here, right? So
you can do, uh, there's a default one that says, Hey, you have a new call generated from Little Rock
Concrete, or you can do a custom one. If you want to like, Hey, Nick, uh, you have a call from
Little Rock Concrete, like put in my business owner's name there. Uh, do you ask, does this
take place a call rail? Yes. You can put in, uh, you, your numbers that exist now already,
if you want to, or excuse me, or you can, uh, get new numbers through program of voice SMS.
So let's say I have a call rail account. What I is there's a way to like bring all my numbers in and
then get rid of my call rail account. Yeah. So we're going to do a number of, uh, porting, uh,
in the future, right? We don't have porting set up, but what you can do is you can keep that number
there. You don't have to buy numbers here. Uh, your numbers are included with your subscription
up to a certain amount. Um, and then, uh, you can just add in your numbers here into your
sites, into your site portfolio, right? Where you just type in what the number is instead of
add a new one. So you keep that for now, your existing sites, you'd keep your call rail account
and keep those numbers and, uh, and then you're, but going forward, new numbers,
you could buy directly through this, through Twilio. And then once we, uh, add porting as
part of, as one of the new features, then, um, you can go ahead and, and we could get rid of that.
Absolutely. Yep. Yep. Um, and the cool thing about these numbers is on the backend,
they have got a feature that I love is that you can do, if you do Google business profile
verifications, you can do those through, uh, these numbers, through, uh, the call,
whereas call rail blocks that. It doesn't let you do it. So, uh, pretty neat little, um, difference
there. Here's the real moneymaker for me. I would not even do local lead generation if not for what
I'm about to show you guys. Like I would not do it. It would be too frustrating for me.
And that is SMS notifications. So, um, when the call comes in by default, this is enabled.
It's going to show you have a new lead from, and then it shows the site name automatically
pulled in and then the caller's number. And so that business owner, every time they get a call,
uh, it says you have a new lead from, and it shows that, that phone number. And so it keeps you
top of their mind. They are thinking like, okay, I'm getting these leads. They're still coming in.
We've already blocked out the spam because we turned on spam filtering and they're getting
this text message. And every time that they get that new lead coming in, they're seeing the value
of your service. So this has been like the number one most valuable thing for me in my agency.
I've baked it into a rank and run engine. So just from the jump, you've got access to it.
I love that. That's it's so valuable because it, um, you like, even if you, even if it's only 10
leads or 15 leads or whatever, just constantly reminding them, you know, that you're there,
Hey, you know, it's like, you're poking them and say, Hey dude, that's me. That's me. That's me.
Cause a lot of times these business owners, even though it's coming from you, they want to assume
it's from their own stupid little go daddy site. And, and they would do everything to be like,
Oh, I don't think so. I don't think so. Right. This is going to show them that like, this does,
this does indeed come from you. So this is a great retention tool. And for those of us that
have done nothing for retention and still retained people, imagine this is just going to be one more,
you know, a nail in the coffin to keep these people just locked in with us. So, um, and by
the way, uh, did you enable that or is that default? By default, they have this, you could
customize it and change it, right. You put in, you know, a name or whatever, right. But by default,
they get an SMS lead notification. I could see really buttering up the business owner and be
like, hello, boss. Uh, here's a little call. Yeah. Something like that. Anyway. Yeah, man.
Yeah. So, uh, you get all your tracking numbers in here. You can get a new one straight through
the platform, right? So, you know, if you want to get, you know, your, your new tracking number,
you can get it, configure it just like I showed you guys a second ago. Right now it's just the
U S my idea. Love you, man. Sorry. It's not there for New Zealand yet, but we'll get you hooked up.
Um, and then you'll, uh, be able to get those numbers, but, uh, right now it's just the U S
but it's, it's, you know, it's everywhere in the U S so, uh, you can get those numbers and you can
see your first ones are included for free on your account. Beautiful. How many, how many are included
for free? Uh, your first five on your, if you do ignition, if you do full throttle, sorry, ignition,
it's five turbo charges, 20 in full throttle. It's 50. Those are the three different levels.
Okay. Beautiful. And then you can, you can add your own, uh, as well, right? So you can do add
on numbers, uh, very affordably. So, uh, let's co can we cover one more, one more, uh, feature
and then we can do a few questions and we can, uh, let anyone, we can share the beta information
that want the people that want to, uh, get on the beta for a discount.
For sure. Yeah. So, uh, we're going to cover this last one here, but, you know,
I'm just going to run through these. You can do site portfolio. All your sites are in one spot,
uh, put in all your sites, prospects, put in all your prospects, clients, all your clients show
up here, right? You can put in the service type SEO lead generation paid advertising,
your subscription type, et cetera, uh, put in all your leads. You can check all your leads here,
and then you can see all your calls and the recordings. But the one I'll show you guys is
this one. Uh, this is site analyzer. So this will allow you to go in and look at the performance of
your own sites or look at your competition sites. So I put in, you know, one of my Legion sites here
and, you know, you can see all the essential metrics at these cards, the top citation flow,
trust flow, domain authority, page authority. Are you improving at these metrics over time
to outrank your competition? Um, you can see your backlink profile, right? Like how many are you
gaining the last 12 months? Uh, how many of you gained a loss over the last 12 months, right? Uh,
here, this gets a little bit technical. I'll probably don't have time for all this, but
gets into your referring IPs, your referring subnet nets and your external backlinks, and then, uh,
your top referring domains, which you want some diversity on. So, uh, referring domains, uh,
all times showing all the, the top ones where you're getting backlinks from basically and what,
their trust flow and citation flow looks like. And then your anchor texts, right? Like how much
anchor text diversity do you have and, uh, what kind of referring domains, all the essential
information that you need that will give you an insight into the performance of your own
lead generation site. And, you know, you can put in competitors too, right? So you can do your own
or you can do another one, but, um, all that data gets piped into this, this one, uh, dashboard for
you. Is it safe? You analyze it and then does it just read, when you put the new one, it doesn't
get rid of this. Is it just like a standing tool or does it save past searches? Yeah, it'll put
a new one in. So let's do, uh, oh, I didn't do that commonplace. Um, this is for like, uh,
assessing a site at a time. If you want to do a due diligence record, you could pull that in
for due diligence, right? So if I go back, it's just gonna, it's gonna refresh it. Um, but we'll
add a, um, search history, like, uh, you know, here's the ones that you've done, the results
that they got. So we'll add that in the future. Yeah. Beautiful. Okay. I think that's something
we should add. I think it'd be nice. Concrete. One thing I want to mention guys is you can finish,
you can finish this. Let me, so each one of these tabs is basically replacing a software tool,
right? Like that's how, like I was just looking at it. Task tracker. Um, we, I mean, we've used all
kinds of different stuff. I told you, we used to use, uh, like, what's this? There's notion,
right? We use notion for task tracker, then the due diligence. We used Google sheets and we used
SEMrush and then the site portfolio. We would use, uh, we used everything from Asana
to Google sheets to pipe. Like I don't know what else we use. We said that was prospect pipeline.
I used pipe drive client list. We use Entraport, like lead tracker, call rail. It's like every
single one of these I was paying or using a different tool. Even if I wasn't paying,
I had to go and toggle between all these tabs. And now each one of these little tabs on the
left here is replacing a piece of software, putting it into one place that you can just,
you know, scale your entire agency from, which is incredible. Money loves speed.
That's the goal, man. Put it all in one spot. It doesn't need to be in 10 different places.
It just creates inefficiencies. Here's the most important part. Can I put my own profile picture
in the corner? For somebody like me, that's real. You can put it in the goofy avatars, right?
Okay. But you can actually upload a picture. Yeah, you can upload your picture.
Amazing. Obviously guys, that's not the most important thing, but I thought it's kind of a
nice little touch. Okay. So let me look at this really quick. We have a few minutes. I'm super
pumped to get my team in playing with it, me getting in playing with it.
Let's just do a couple of questions. Then we're going to share the information on the beta. Okay.
So let's see. Man, we got so many questions. Let me start at the bottom, actually.
Jahil says, I joined late, but I have a question about the site portfolio section. Is there some
type of filtering system where we can split sites we have rented from the sites we don't have rented?
Yeah, for sure. So you could show ones that are in development, right? And those are basically
unlimited, right? You could put just tons of in-development ones in there. And then when
the development status is complete, you could put a market is complete and then edit whatever
details you need to in here, right? So you can do your service type by lead generation, SEO,
paid advertising, whatever your site is, and then indicate whether you actually have a client on it.
So under your client list, you can tie it to a website, right? So that website will be assigned
to a client and then they'll know if it's rented. Beautiful. Okay. Jeremy says, hey Ryan, congrats
on building such a promising tool. It looks really great. Sorry if they've already been asked. I'm on
the job. So you got a couple of questions. Let's rapid fire. And I know some of the answers,
so I'll answer them. Can we bring in our own Twilio numbers, bring your own key style or
must we purchase them in rare? They'll eventually be able to be ported in. In the meantime,
what you can do is you can, when you create a site, you can just put in the phone number,
the number you like to tracking number, or you can just add your own.
Perfect. Number two, he says, if not, can we pour our tracking numbers in out of rare?
Not yet, but that is, that has been asked a couple of times. So that's going to be at the top of what
we want to, we want to update the next update. Okay. Does it have a web browser dialer in it
so we can call the leads via the website tracking number? I don't think so right now.
No. Okay. And again, guys, as it's crazy, because as you guys are asking these questions, it's,
it would be really impossible to cover like from, remember this is version like, you know, 1.0,
it's a version 2.0 of rare, but this is version 1.0 of this being an actual tool. And I think
you've covered basically everything. So of course, there's going to be these little teeny
things that are nice, whatever, but just keep in mind, there are going to be a lot of updates
coming. This is just where we're starting at. Okay. One more question. He asks, he said, I see
on your website, it says you only support USA number at this time. Do you have an estimated
timeline for Canada and other countries? I don't know if we have a timeline, but of course,
by popular demand, it's probably the order that we'll tackle. It'll probably be Canada slash
Australia would be the second one. And then of course, Mike V, we got to hook up Mike V. He's
over there just carrying the whole country on his back over there in New Zealand. New Zealand love.
Yes. Okay. And then let's keep just a couple more and then we're going to have to go through
and just answer these. Bruce says, one last question. Will you be doing a bit further
training inside of the rare Facebook group? Yeah. So I made a ranking or an engine Facebook group.
We can share that here, basically for this community, people using this platform. So if you
guys want to join that, just search ranking or an engine and jump in. There's not much there right
now, but I intend to share more trainings and more product roadmap and things like that. So you guys
are constantly getting the latest from me in there as well. Let's answer one more question and we'll
get into beta stuff. Luke Hill, and I think this is important, he says, so why wouldn't Google give
that on Google Keyword Planner or why wouldn't other tools like Ahrefs or SEMrush use the same
API? Why do you think that is? Because we're talking about how this data isn't going to third
parties. Why do you think they're not using that? Good question. I can't speak for why other
platforms were built the way that they were. Every keyword tool has its little nuances,
has its differences, right? For our industry, we are very focused on the local search volume,
the local keywords. There's nothing built for that. It's like, what is the fastest path to
knowing in that local market what that search volume is, what that cost per click is, right?
So I chose like, hey, the gold standard for this after running, you know, I've ran probably $300,
$400,000 of ads now is going to come from Google, right? That is the place to get the gold standard
of information and data for me. And so I wanted to tie that in, right? I can't speak to some of
these other choices for the way they build theirs. They're catering off into much bigger
corporations, right? Like how many people are searching for sneakers by Nike, right? You know,
that's not what we're doing. And so I built our tool bespoke for our use case.
Which I think is super interesting because a lot of people with tools, they want to, they're like
thinking, well, I want to, I want to build this tool so that we can get people in this industry,
in this industry, in this industry want to make. And of course, this is a moneymaking product.
Ryan's isn't just a charity. However, Ryan makes his money from doing rank and rent. And so this is
not only, of course, it's a way to make money, but it's also a way to scale his rank and rent
agency even further. And so I think the best products, the best tools always come from people
inside that industry because they know the pain points. Whereas somebody from the outside coming
in to build it just to make money, it's never going to cater exactly because they don't know
those pains. So anyway, let's, we only have a couple of minutes, right? How do people,
and I'm going to try it. We'll try our best maybe to either do like a Q and a session later,
or just go in and answer these questions. But how do people, if they want to get on the beta
discount, how do they sign up? And what does that look like price wise, et cetera? We have 38 people
on, let's show them that really quick. Give them the link and let them go start playing around with
this amazing tool. For sure. Yeah. Yeah. Nick hooked it up. You guys are getting early access.
So you go to rentandrentengine.com. You can click create a free account. And then for the first 50
people that use Ignition 24, so all capitals, no spaces, Ignition 24, one word, will get 20%
off. So the first tier is 97 bucks a month. You can cancel your main goals. You can cancel your
SEM rush, right? Like you're going to go in here and see that, you know, this is very much a cost
savings tool for you guys. And you're getting 20% off on top of that. What's the code? Ignition 24.
That's the first two months at 20% off. So IGNITION24. We can put it in the, in the chat
or 24, all lowercase, all uppercase. So you know, it's case sensitive, but I just put it in.
Oh, I misspelled it. Time too fast. I don't delete that comment. All right. Ignition 24,
like starting a car night. Beautiful.
Also real quick, Daniel Kelly. Okay, good. I spelled it correctly too. Okay. Daniel Kelly,
go look at your previous comment. I dropped the recommended niches for you specifically. I
spent some time to write that comment out. So guys, if you are interested
on a 20% discount for the first, I think it's 50 people is what it's capped at. What we're,
and by the way, this is coming to you guys first. We haven't taken this to the free group. We haven't
taken this to, you know, whatever. We're going to be doing an official, official, official, official
launch next, probably in about a month, depending on how this beta test goes. Could be as early as
two weeks, but most likely first of November. But yeah, go in, play with this and just know that
you guys are, you guys are our people. We're excited. We want to get as much feedback as
possible. If people have feedback, where would be the best place? Should they go in the Facebook
group and drop a comment? Because I don't want to make a huge mess here, like DMing you and stuff
like that. Where should they go for support? Should they go to the Facebook group and drop a
question, comment? Like what would be the quickest way to give feedback?
Yeah. If they want, it's only positive things that I accept. No, I'm just kidding. If you want to go
to ask feedback, you could talk about it in the Facebook group, but if you want it the
most direct and organized way that I'm categorizing this stuff is when you create an account in this
top corner, you'll get your user profile information, click on support. It's going to pull up this form.
And so this form is going to be refreshed. Here we go. It's your rare user support request form.
So you put in anything that you see in here, hit submit. It's a super short form. It'll go straight
to me, into my email. And so I can see anything going on. And you're also free to DM me as well.
Just find me on Facebook and send me a DM. If you guys would though, I mean, for the benefit
of the community, if you could do that form, it would make it easier for Ryan to address
these things and also update. So I know sometimes you get frustrated when a fire off a message
and, you know, whatever, but if you guys will do that, maybe you do both. If you're really,
it's a really quick thing you want to get answered, but this is going to allow Ryan to continue to
make this tool even better and better. Okay. So one more time. Okay. Shane real quick says,
awesome. Can you increase your package at any time? Sure can. Yep. You can also do add on sites. So
if you've got 10 sites, you can do add on sites as well without having to upgrade your package.
Or you can, you know, choose the highest tier if you want to. Right. So anytime that's available
for you guys. And then Jahil has a good question. He said, how does the search volume, how does the
search volume do when searching for Metmo? That's exactly, well, guys, this tool, as of last week,
right when we went live, that was like when we started basically being able to play with it as
well. So that's one of the things that I'm going to be looking at in the next few weeks
is when we type in a Bentonville concrete, when you type in that, that key site, what is that minimum
search volume? So, uh, stay just a little bit patient with me as we figure that out. I don't
want to come out and say, Oh, when it says this, you know, then that's a, uh, for sure, because I'm
not a hundred percent there yet, but this is now I'm confident because we have control over the tool
that we can give you that with a 90% confidence rating type of thing. So, um, again, guys,
if you are interested in the beta, go to rankandrentengine.com and choose your package.
And then the ignition all caps, we think ignition 24, maybe not case sensitive. I don't know to get
20% off, uh, for the first, how many months? Two months, first two months. And then one more thing,
Matt says, could an overseas VA team call using the tracking numbers? Uh, there's not anything to
have, uh, those dial out right now. Um, but I've got some ideas for that. So stay tuned. Beautiful,
beautiful. Okay. I think we, I mean, I think that's pretty much it guys. Um, go test it out,
play with it. Uh, if you guys are like the lowest package is 99 bucks, 97, you get a 20% discount.
We're at, let's call it 80 bucks, 80 bucks a month. SEM rush is 129 a month, just for the search
volume. Like it's at the lowest package, it's, it's a no brainer, especially with the, with the
discount. Okay. Um, you can use it for SEP. Okay. Anyway, um, Kirk says just registered,
but it's us only, do we lose out on the offer? Any idea on the UK feature?
Uh, so let's see, just registered. That's right. Yep. So it's, it's still just us only, right? So,
um, if you're, if you're in the UK or Canada, Australia, like we've heard you guys, you know,
we want to keep building this out for you guys. We're starting with the U S and then we're going
to expand it out from there. Um, Kurt messaged me when, when that time comes, we'll do something
special for every guy and, uh, gal in the UK. Um, one thing on, uh, dial outs, there are third
party programs that you can use like talking to that you can actually plug in your, uh, SEP
and SID. Oops. Um, this SID, I haven't tested that with this yet. Um, but you guys might be able to,
do it that way, right? So, um, that's, that's a possibility in any case, in the future,
we'll be able to make it to where you guys can use your numbers for dialing out using tools,
um, either natively built in or third party, but, um, that doesn't exist right now.
Beautiful. Ryan Dalton, you've done, you've done miracles, my friend. I'm excited to, uh,
get in play with this myself, get our entire agency over here. And, uh, yeah, anybody else guys,
again, Marcus just shared it one more time. Ignition 24, go to rankinventag.com sign up for
the package and let's, let's, let's go, let's go test this thing out. Let's go and give Ryan
as much feedback as possible and, and start, um, building our agencies on this. Yeah, man,
go build scale and automate. Let's do it. Thanks, Ryan. See you.